[Music]
hello and welcome to playstation grenade
it's been a hot minute since we've
updated our story theories for chapter
two
and now as we approach the first live
event of the new story
i thought we should recap what we know
and predict what will happen next
please let me know which theory you
believe is right and let me know
anything i've missed which you think
need to be part of the storyline but
first before we can predict the future
we need to set the scene so sit your
butt down for 10 minutes think about
using code adamaru in the shop to help
this series continue
and hit the dramatic music
all remember the days before the black
hole the battle to destroy the nexus
and break the cycle for the last two
years but since the reset
and the first time we jumped out of the
battle bus we had a strange feeling
that we'd been here before and at the
same time it felt completely new and
unique
this actually sets up the first two
seasons of chapter two
duality many landmarks are the same but
slightly changed
as if two dimensions had been smashed
together to form this new reality
the only thing we know for certain is
the existence of the seven
an extraterrestrial organization
spanning space and time
pioneering scientific technology and
staying in the shadows wherever possible
before chapter two began we knew of the
existence of three of the seven
the original visitor who was brought to
us via a meteor and who single-handedly
built the rocket
the scientist who arrived after changing
and reversing time and put that rocket
to work
and finally the paradigm who at present
we don't know much about but her name
suggests she's watching always
and her info reads her allegiance is
unknown
in the chapter 2 reveal we saw the 7
briefly mentioned in a carving
reminding us they are out there while
they watched from a distance new
characters arrived
signaling the start of a new storyline
first arrivals on the island were the
ego squad a military unit crash landed
and was sent to set up stable living
arrangements for those who followed
their destroyed plane a constant
reminder we are staying on this island
for the foreseeable future
but here's where the duality point
becomes key all the main characters
had seemingly evil versions of
themselves which were revealed over the
course of season 1.
in our last story update we surmised
that the alter egos were like a
defensive mechanism
the island set in place to keep all its
secrets
and due to the lack of a live event then
we never really knew who won that war
the egos or the altars what we did find
out though is that the ego logo when
turned upside down
is actually the bunker so we waited here
for six months for answers
nothing ever happened and then season
two began
season two took the battle between
shadow and ghost
and put us in charge of what happens we
would decide
who won the war but we were never
actually told who were the good guys
every fortnight we chose which character
pledged their allegiance to each faction
and we quickly discovered shadow was
becoming powerful
shadow took the grotto signified by this
evil skull design
and quickly followed up by taking the
rig well more than taking the rig
the rig was destroyed both were very
evil acts
right so does that tell us that shadow
are the enemy and ghosts
are the good guys former characters we
knew from previous seasons were revealed
to be
agents too from lynx to the bushranger
so this secret agent thing has been
going on for many many months now
we never knew lynx has been with us
since december 2018 and the bushranger
arrived in may 2019.
their secret impact is already around us
firstly
links knows mousels take a look back at
the loading screen back in 2018
and it showed us his existence all the
way back then
and then here's a creepy one look at
when 8th ball and scratch fought last
season
look who is watching and reporting back
to their superiors
it's the bush ranger the weeks rolled on
and the change is too and now in the
last few moments of the season we see
the agency the last ego stronghold
currently held by the ghost squad it's
under threat
the agency a picture of golden
perfection with some of the best artwork
you will ever see in a video game
just drink it in for a moment nice
so let's look at the ringleader here the
person in charge the one all the agents
report
to it's midas midas is a flamboyant man
with a desire to look good
and be surrounded by items and
possessions only the rich can afford
his yacht is the pinnacle of this
arrogance but
at the moment deadpool has ransacked it
and that will have a lasting effect on
midas
i'm sure you know this but midas is
named after the greek myth about a king
who wanted so much wealth that he wished
that everything he touched
turned to gold here in fortnite our
midas has the same ability
we are unsure if midas is a hero or a
villain right now
but when we finally saw inside midas
quarters
it became almost impossible to deny
midas is the bad guy here
and he's up to something very
questionable the first thing we see is
the gold touch
taking the masks of many fortnite
characters including lynx
and even the og black knight lynx was
his co-worker
so why would he do this the general
theory is that midas has a plan which he
doesn't want to reveal no one will know
about this
and should someone find out like links
they are removed from service
and eliminate it with midas keeping a
memento of everyone he's taken down
like a real james bond villain the
problem he'll find by taking out links
though
is mousels those two obviously share a
pass together
especially as this hench cat has a [ __ ]
stamp to show his love
what will happen when mousels finds out
another mask we should pay attention to
is that of the chaos agent
once believed to be the villain of this
entire piece it's quickly become
apparent
midas has eliminated him too chaos agent
was the symbol of the altars
and was renowned for his experiments
creating abominations like
ripley utilizing anything he could find
on the planet he's currently on
his crowning moment was to create the
kevolution of ripley
and at this point midas has seen enough
and took over his operations
now powered by the science of the chaos
agent to combine with his finances
and troops to sacrifice midas built what
looks to be a group of silos around the
agency
which could be connected to the power
plant as a purple glow is growing inside
but the question remains why why is he
doing this
a little subtle hint that midas is
officially not to be trusted
can be found in the audio track from the
store named
subdifuge which literally means to use
deceit
to achieve your goals midas is not to be
trusted i repeat
do not trust midas sorry i was i was
having flashbacks of shepard then
in madison's room we have so many clues
but what are red herrings and what are
the real deal
firstly over in the background we can
see that midas continues the chaos
agents work
he is building a doomsday machine likely
in conjunction with those hatches in the
water
i know about two doomsday machines which
could help us get an idea of upcoming
events
in science fiction the doomsday machine
is also known as the planet eater
in which you've guessed it it consumes
all land mass reducing space and time to
a black hole
sounds familiar right the second use of
the doomsday machine is the doomsday
clock used here on our real earth
to show everyone how quickly the planet
could be wiped out
if that hand ever reaches midnight we
are no more
this could be due to many factors but
mainly nuclear war
and as we all know nuclear warheads come
from missile silos
kinda like these so just from those two
examples we know that doomsday
is a very bad thing for everyone so now
let's look at why midas
is doing this we have two major theories
both around the golden touch ability
look around midas room and you'll see a
photo on his desk
of a loved one we may be reaching here
but it's likely this
is his wife or girlfriend but we have
never seen her in the flesh
could he be responsible for accidentally
touching her and slowly causing her to
turn
into a gold statue an interesting theory
is that midas has been utilizing the
work of the chaos agent
to bring his loved one back from a gold
death
and the doomsday machine is an attempt
to destroy everything in the hopes of
spending one final moment
with his beloved oh in that cute
everything he has done
is for the chance to see her again and
no one will get in his way
this would explain where midas removed
the chaos agent from his leadership role
he knew too much and midas couldn't risk
his secret leaking to other members of
the team
the same can be said for links she may
have stumbled across midas
plans and once again unwilling to trust
her midas gives her the same fate
he's trying to save his wife from his
secret will come out sooner or later
and will likely be taking a side in the
upcoming live event
it could be as simple as pressing a
button and watching the world
burn the theory of destruction also
leads into another returning element on
the map
the no sweat insurance the one place
which can save buildings and locations
from impending destruction
and right away they have set up and
begun to protect those who need them
the posters here look to show a flooded
map once again feeding into the doomsday
machine
and its earth eating abilities in fact
the more we look
across this theory the more it makes
sense as we've just witnessed the first
use of
underwater gameplay in fortnite thanks
to travis scott
a flooded island would tie in everything
together with decaying locations
everywhere
that would also make sense as to why
deadpool was once stuck under water
we shall see i suppose there's another
theory we can also look into
and that refers to the oro skin
[Music]
have you noticed the similarities
between midas and oro
i mean they both like gold obviously but
check out the scar on their faces
it matches up are they the same person
we know that midas did not have the scar
well at least when the statue was
created on the yacht
amazingly right now in game though it's
been renovated
by wade wilson but why would they have
matching scars
using greek myth again we can surmise
that oro is indeed king midas wearing
the crown of gold of a king and the
clothing of a regal leader too
it may be a little on the nose but has
king midas found a way to communicate
with the living
has there been a pact between the two
realities
the subtext from the character hints of
a relationship between midas and oro
stating harness his power and gets
revenge
now we know that midas has at least seen
oro by the fact that his pickaxe
is in his room at the agency and those
matching scars
are just too much to deny a pact between
the living and dead seems frightening to
me
and imagine if there was a character who
could bring others back to life
oh my god that's the wraith isn't it wow
hang on then if this is about living and
dead and space and time then we actually
could end up on the chapter one island
again next season
nah let's not get our hopes up
right now the doomsday machine is
becoming too big to hide
the others have noticed and so of many
of us leading us to now be forced to
take a side
trust midas even though everything looks
to be leading to a
sinister future or fight back now and
save parts of the island from
destruction
choose meowsles and take revenge for
links or help midas find his love
who may be able to engineer a way out of
this
in season three we have so many more
questions than answers right now
and we still wait for the paradigm to be
shifted yet again i'm adam from
playstation grenade
it's been a pleasure thank you very much
for listening to me drone on for 10
[Music]
minutes
[Music]
[Music]
you